donald trump held another series of
rallies yesterday
and at this sort of late stage in the
election with just
five days remaining and nearly 80
million votes already cast
the rallies are becoming dramatically
more unhinged
you can track it on a day-to-day basis
now part of it may be exhaustion on
donald trump's behalf part of it maybe
desperation but yesterday
was wacky and out there now first of all
a really strange moment in arizona trump
brought out congressman kevin mccarthy
who i guess wants to be speaker of the
house if republicans take the house next
week
which they won't republicans are not
taking the house next week
and he said he wouldn't bang
nancy pelosi with the gavel a bizarre
moment
it'll be before we swear in the
president again
but the reason why i want you to come i
want you to watch
nancy pelosi hand me that gavel
and i promise you this
[Applause]
i won't bang her with it but i'll bang
the end to the socialism
and yes to america really strange stuff
there and trump now
is regularly complaining about the
weather and the temperature at his
rallies
it's either too cold or too hot or too
windy
arizona i guess was too hot for him and
i'm sitting in the hottest sun i've ever
felt
this is hot
my last stop also in your great state it
had a different problem the sun was hot
i've never seen wind like that
it's lucky i don't need teleprompters
like sleepy joe because the
teleprompters were falling down they
were going all over the place i was
getting a headache i'm trying to look
but i have a good memory i remember
things
now he said he doesn't need a
teleprompter
while using a teleprompter in that clip
but is anybody else sick of the whining
this is the whiniest president i can
remember
leslie stahl wasn't fair and twitter's
not
fair and the fake news isn't fair and
it's too
cold and now it's too hot and it's too
windy and it's too sunny and i'm too
sweaty
this is the most privileged man in
america
and he thinks he's the biggest victim he
can't stop complaining
in this next clip trump actually doesn't
know what
city he's in this is this is the best
trump doesn't know what city he's in
and even though he criticizes biden for
using a prompter
he struggles to read the name of the
city he's in off of the prompter because
it's windy
mesa to human and from phoenix to right
here
in bullhead
that sucker is moving so much i see
bullets
i'm trying to go up and is my head
moving up and down like this
you did a great job of anchoring these
things fellas a great job
yeah trump who has been accusing his
opponent of cognitive decline
doesn't know what city he's in unless he
reads it off a prompter
which he criticizes joe biden for using
and trump then claims
uh this is now in bullhead city arizona
trump still ridiculing masks as we have
more than 233 thousand coronavirus
deaths
[Applause]
with sleepy joe there'd be no
graduations no weddings no thanksgiving
they're already talking about no
thanksgiving
and in california you have a special
mass you cannot
under any circumstances take it off you
have to eat through the mask and say
right right charlie it's it's a very
complex
mechanism and they don't realize those
germs they go through it like nothing
they look at you with that contraption
and they say that's an easy one i'll go
right through with the food
now how about california though where
you're supposed to eat
with the mask can't take it up okay so
then the audio problem started with
insane wind
and people on stage behind trump pulling
their masks off
just everything going wrong both of you
states
the bike
[Music]
these guys yeah that's right you can't
maybe uh
now it's probably a rhino is operating
they're having a bad day today they're
having a bad day but we're having a good
day
thank you these rallies have become
parodies of themselves truly
and i the audio issues continue
this next video i don't know why this
next one i found so funny
i was crying from laughter last night to
the po as i was preparing
this clip to the point where my
girlfriend came up to my office and
started filming me
watching this clip and laughing
hysterically i don't know why i find
this so funny
but i do and are incredible
oh these people don't know what the hell
they're doing
let me recover my ears for one
[Applause]
whoever did this microphone don't pay
him
uh these people there's also something i
mean it's horrible
but it's also in a way very trumpian
to immediately start attacking workers
saying they don't know what the hell
they're doing
as far as audio equipment is concerned
one audio tech sent me a message on
twitter saying
uh i'm an audio tech the whoever is
working the audio is really doing god's
work by interfering with donald trump's
speech
and then under the category of complete
and total lies just complete lies that
make no sense
donald trump claims that joe biden wants
to ban
weddings graduations and even
thanksgiving
[Applause]
with sleepy joe there'd be no
graduations no weddings no thanksgiving
they're already talking about no
thanksgiving
and in california you have a special
mass you cannot
under any circumstances take it off you
have to eat through the mask and say
do you think anybody really believes
that
or are even his supporters seeing it as
sort of performance theater meant just
to get a reaction
and then at the earlier rally trump
complained as i mentioned
not about the heat but about the wind
you know it's windy as hell out here
you know i said is it windy should i
bring a hat
because i don't love my hair flopping
around one thing
at least they figured out after three
years that it is mine if it wasn't i
would have found out about it
just stay home maybe like don't do the
rallies if it's either too windy or too
hot or too cold or too sunny or too dark
just stay home and don't do it because
quite frankly all you're really doing is
spreading coronavirus
and in some cases giving old folks
hypothermia
um and these are all trump voters anyway
you're not convincing anybody with these
rallies
i would say just stay home the next five
days he doesn't plan to though that's
for sure
one of our sponsors today is hydrant and
they're giving my audience
25 off your first order hydrant has been
great for me
it's this delicious electrolyte powder
made with real fruit juice
you mix it into water for great tasting
rehydration
with low sugar packed with electrolytes
but way more cost effective than those
high sugar sports drinks
comes in flavors like lime fruit punch
orange mango
they have no sugar varieties which come
in lemonade and pink grapefruit
they also have a new product line called
immunity
which adds vitamins b c and d and they
have a version with caffeine
if you're looking for that type of boost
staying hydrated helps my focus
and keeps my energy up and hydrant has
been a great way for me to do that as
part of my daily routine
they have a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drinkhydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video